une haie d'honneur pour bruno pu le
professeur deux ps n'en croit pas ses
yeux
[Applaudissements]
circus
mais la présence de notre caméra
l'intriguent
tout comme ce voile posé sur la porte de
son bureau
43 ans dans le même établissement c'est
rare on a souhaité que cet engagement
soit plus visible à la fois pour les
gens qui sont là aujourd'hui mais aussi
pour ceux qui viendront
et c'est vrai que bruno en a vu courir
des milliers d'élèves cette plaque
gravée à son nom c'est la plus belle des
médailles je sais que j'ai pas toujours
été facile à vivre j'ai pas t'es sympa
avec tout le monde je le reconnais cm je
pense avoir été juste toute ma carrière
il peut être dur mais il nous a
bousculés
et ça nous a apporté beaucoup de choses
dans notre scolarité il nous pousse à
dépasser nos limites et ça fait du bien
aujourd'hui on le remercie pour tout ce
qui nous a fait bruno a été le
professeur de sport de sema pendant ses
jeunes années plus que le professeur
c'est le collègue qu'elle regrette déjà
je suis très très heureuse et de ces
deux années qu'on a partagé et que le
temps passe vite et de savoir qu'un
monument comme celui-là samba je pense
que ça va nous faire bizarre à la
rentrée
si j'avais pu continuer j'aurais
continué peut-être encore un an mais
l'administration autant si elle fait ce
qu'elle est pardon je me dois de rendre
les armes et bruno ne compte pas
raccrocher les gants de sitôt à la
rentrée il sera consultant sportif pour
les futurs champions d'athlétisme du
collège merci à tous mais je ne suis pas
totalement partie vous me reverrez en
septembre
[Applaudissements]